another character from a Star Wars
Animated Series has made a stunning
debut in live action and his brief Cameo
has fans predicting big things to come
what could zeb's Mandalorian debut mean
just as fans had calmed down after the
surprising sight of giant space whales
in the opening episode of the third
season of the Mandalorian a very
familiar lasat walked into a bar causing
a stir without even realizing it
why'd it have to be me yes that really
was Star Wars Rebels hero and former
ghost crew member garazeb Aurelius AKA
Zeb speaking to Carson Teva now rendered
into live action with purple cgi-infused
flesh he was a Site for Sore Eyes for
fans of the popular animated series it
also came as a total shock given that
the character hasn't been seen since the
finale of The Animated show in 2018. if
you spat your blue milk in total
disbelief don't worry you weren't the
only one brought to life by voice artist
Steve bloom in 2014 there was a
much-loved muscle of the ghost Rebel
faction alongside Ezra Bridger
admittedly those that skipped the
Animated Series might not have been
excited about just another alien this is
Star Wars after all but Rebels fans were
understandably buzzed to see zebra life
and in Europe public threats of course
with a cameo of this size it was
inevitable that Reddit would begin
firing off theories about where he's
been and what it could mean not just for
the future of the Mandalorian but future
Star Wars series as well Zeb is hardly
the first animated Star Wars character
to debut in live action Ahsoka Boca tan
craze and cadbane have all shown up in
the Mandalorian and the Book of Boba
Fett even so fans are trying to rub
their heads around what they were seeing
with zeb's appearance some needed time
to process with one saying on Reddit
Star Wars subreddit I had to pause for a
straight minute to process that voice
was too familiar thankfully other
keynote fans already knew exactly who it
was one added I'd recognize Steve
Bloom's iconic Gruff draw anywhere great
to finally see what the last member of
the ghost crew got up to after Rebels
all in all the Channel's response to
Zed's surprise appearance was
overwhelmingly positive another fan
wrote Rebels is my favorite of the
animated shows so I was super mega pumps
I really want him to be in more stuff
now not your attitude good luck the
spiders quick drop in fans are already
speculating if there's more space for
Zeb to return either in Mundo's ongoing
Adventure or another upcoming series
they can't wait to see one Reddit still
was certain and already willing to place
a bet writing we are absolutely getting
a full Rebels reunion in the Ahsoka
series and I couldn't be happier another
fan on the subreddit was already turning
their gaze toward even further Rebels
seemed live-action debuts they expressed
hope that Zeb joining the live-action
Star Wars Ensemble might indicate that
another Rebels Mainstay might also be
due for a grand entrance Sabine ran I
love how casually they dropped this
Cameo and It just fits now is it too
much to hope for Sabine perhaps in the
season finale regardless of how big
zeb's role will be in the Mandalorian or
other Disney plus Star Wars shows going
forward his cameo in this episode is
certainly giving fans hope for great
things to come with Star Wars
celebration just around the corner he
won't have long to find out if that
really is the case
foreign